A little over a year ago,
I made a video talking about learning the joys of home making
and the responses were very interesting.
Half were very encouraging and half were like,
what the heck? Why doesn't your husband help you?
So I just wanted to clear up a few things
a year later about common misconceptions about home making.
Number one, home making is not just for women.
Home making is for anyone and everyone who cares about stewarding
their home whatever.
In our home, that looks like splitting a lot of the chores.
Jacob does the dishes half the time.
I do it the other half of the time.
He takes out the trash, I take care of laundry.
You get the job. Misconception number two
is that you have to be a stay at home mom or wife
and you have to be able to make sourdough.
That's just not true.
There is an aesthetic that has been made online about home making
and I definitely lean into it a little bit
because it's fun to put on a pretty dress
and make things from scratch,
but it is not the norm.
Misconception number three is that this is my only job
and this is all I do. That's not true.
I do social media full time
along with working with the cast of Little House on the parade.
I hope that I can encourage you to find the joy of home making,
cause it really is A joy